[Musique]
enfin au terme de quelle analyse et doit
arriver à votre conclusion et aux
décisions dont vous avez fait pas aux
français oui le 29 mai qu j'ai eu la
tentation de me retirer
et puis en même temps j'ai pensé que si
je partais la subversion menaçante
allait déferler et emporter la
république
alors une fois de plus je me suis résolu
vous savez depuis quelque chose comme
trente ans que j'ai à faire à l'histoire
il m'est arrivé
quelquefois de me demander si je ne
devais pas la quitter
ce fut le cas par exemple
en septembre
1940 après dakar
ou avec mes compagnons ayant essuyé le
feu des forces françaises qui tirait sur
les français libres alors que l'ennemi
était à paille
j'ai douté qu'on ne pourrait jamais d'y
retourner contre l'envahisseur de la
france
c'était le cas
à londres en mars 1942 ou devant une
dissidence à l'intérieur de la france
libre dissidence dans le gouvernement
britannique avait été le complice sinon
l'instigateur
je suis allé dans un coin de la campagne
anglaise en faisant savoir à londres que
je ne poursuivrait pas mon entreprise
aux côtés de la grande-bretagne
si mes conditions n'étaient pas
acceptées
ce fut le cas en
quand submergé par le torrent stérile
des parties sur lequel j'avais pas prise
et ne pouvant plus agir à la place où
j'étais je les quitte et
ce fut le cas en dix-neuf sens
non du point de vue de l'homme la
solution communiste est mauvaise
le capitalisme dit
grâce aux profits qui suscite
l'initiative
fabriquons
de plus en plus de richesses qui en se
répartissant par le libre marché élève
en somme le niveau du corps social tout
entier
seulement voilà la propriété la
direction le bénéfice des entreprises
graal système capitaliste n'appartient
qu'au capital et alors ce qu'ils ne
possèdent pas se trouve dans une sorte
d'état des lieux et nation à l'intérieur
même
de l'activité à la cayrie contribuent
non
le capitalisme du point de vue de
l'homme
n'offrent pas de solution satisfaisante
il ya une troisième solution
c'est la participation qui elle change
la condition de l'homme au milieu de la
civilisation moderne
dès lors que des gens
se mettent ensemble
pour une oeuvre économique commune par
exemple pour faire marcher une industrie
en importants soient les capitaux
nécessaires
soit la capacité de direction de gestion
et de technique soit le travail
il s'agit que tous
forment ensemble une société
une société
où tout cet intérêt à son rendement et à
son bon fonctionnement est un intérêt
direct
ça implique
que soient attribués de par la loi à
chacun
une part de ce que la fergane
et de ce qu' elle investit en elle-même
grâce à ses gains
cela implique aussi
que tous soit informée d'une manière
suffisante de la marche de l'entreprise
et puis ce par des représentants qu'ils
auront tous nommés librement
participer
à la société et à ses conseils pour y
faire valoir leurs intérêts leurs points
de vue et leurs propositions
c'est la voie que j'ai toujours cru
bonne oui c'est la voie dans laquelle
j'ai fait déjà quelques pas par exemple
en 1945 quand avec mon gouvernement j'ai
institué les comités d'entreprise quand
en 1959 et en 1967 j'ai partisans de
nantes ouvert la brèche à
l'intéressement
c'est la voie dans laquelle ils vont
marcher donc ce que je voudrais là
encore vous demandez mon général vous
avez dit l'autre jour qu'il fallait
changer l'université tout le monde est
d'accord il faut la changer la vieille
université université de pau a appelé
l'université de papa a vécu vous êtes
d'accord pour changer d'université
comment encore une fois est-ce que vous
comptez dans les grandes lignes bien
entendu vous y prendre pour accomplir
cette mutation est essentielle changer
d'université et là aussi encore une fois
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
commencé plus tôt
dans cette crise
qui s'est passé à l'université il y
avait deux jours
il y avait d'abord
l'angoissent des jeunes les étudiants
qui est infiniment naturel je viens je
crois de l'expliquer dans la société
mécanique la société de consommation
moderne parce qu'elle leur offre pas ce
dont ils ont besoin c'est à dire un
idéal un élan un espoir et moi je pense
que cet idéal c'était lent et cet espoir
ils peuvent et doivent les trouver dans
la participation
et puis il ya eu
la crise de l'université elle même qui a
étalé sa caducité
son impuissance à se réformer et puis
pour finir son effondrement malgré la
valeur intellectuelle très grande de
beaucoup de ses maîtres
y a pas de doute que cette université
est à reconstruire complètement
au long des siècles l'ancien régime
nos facultés qui étaient répartis sur le
territoire
menait une existence
distinctes et avait des fortunes très
diverses et souvent même d'ailleurs très
agitée
napoléon aidé par fanta n'a fait de tout
ça un grand corps
dans un certain but
et d'une certaine façon
le but c'était de faire accéder aux
sommets les plus élevés au sommet
théorique de la connaissance
un nombre assez restreint d'étudiants
après quoi l'élite ainsi dégagé se
répartissaient comme elle voulait et un
titre de pépinières d'hommes supérieur
et la façon c'était
des cours
professer ex cathedra par des maîtres et
puis des examens qui aboutissaient à des
diplômes lesquels diplôme
ne
déterminait pas du tout nécessairement
le détenteur
à une carrière précise et déterminée
et
l'engagé pas du tout les employeurs est
le pendant
d'abord il ya le communisme qui dit
créons
d'office
le plus possible de biens matériels
et répartissant les offices de telle
sorte que personne n'en disposent à
moins qu'on ne l'y autorise comment
par la contrainte la contrainte morale
et matérielle
constante autrement dit par une
dictature
qui est implacable et perpétuelle même
si à l'intérieur d'elle-même des clans
différents s'en saisissent tour à tour
en se vouant aux gémonies
même si depuis que ce système est en
vigueur dans certains endroits
ces chefs à mesure qu'ils se succèdent
se condamne les uns les autres
comme s'il était prouvé d'avant ce
que
chacun devrait échouer à moins qu'il ne
trahisse
il faut qu'elle corresponde aux besoins
modernes de notre pays
notre pays à des activités diverses
et parfaitement distincts les unes des
autres
eh bien il faut
que l'université et c'est ce que le pays
lui demande que l'université lui
fournisse des élites
adaptés à chacune de ses activités là
ce qui veut dire
que chaque discipline universitaire doit
correspondre directement un certain
domaine pratique et qu'inversement ce
domaine pratique assure des débouchés
aux étudiants qui ont été formés dans
cette discipline là
[Musique]